[Music]
with its sudden and unprecedented
popularity with young people and outrage
from old people in the early to mid 90s
the Mortal Kombat franchise quickly
began to expand and new in unexpected
ways there were toys cartoons comics
references all over pop culture you can
do your shopping at home or in a
theatrically released movie don't worry
we'll get to that one he'll get to all
of it so the games naturally had to
start evolving as the series popularity
grew and one year after the movie Mortal
Kombat finally made the leap to 3d
consoles such as the space station one
and the never end o 67 after cementing
itself so firmly in the world of gaming
and cultural consciousness transitioning
from digitized actors to a 3d system
seems like it would be rather easy right
huh boy I think it's safe to say out of
the three games made for mk in this era
all of them are just not games all right
before we get back to the fun stuff I
got to get these out of the way we got
to talk about this beautiful disaster
and it's two adjunct parasitic tumors so
the PlayStation 1 era of gaming is when
cinematic storytelling in games was
really starting to take a foothold it
was an expectation now to have voice
acting cutscenes lore the works while it
worked really well for some games others
struggled to function that way usually
if one thing was good there was always
another part that was iffy let games
with great bore and world building and
even fantastic level design but the
voice acting in cutscenes are and games
with good voice acting but the cutscenes
lacked a little graphically games with
gorgeous cutscenes but the voice acting
that was so it's not to say MK 4 was the
only game around this time struggling to
give you the full package but the team
behind it
really didn't have that much experience
with any of these new concepts so all of
it is bad voice acting is all over the
place the cutscenes our mess and the
graphics are about standard for ps1
which ironically feels a step down from
what they had before
despite being a more primitive method of
creating characters well to start the
gameplay is serviceable it plays about
how a normal MK game plays but the
animations are a little silly in certain
things look too fast
apparently this is because Ed Boon
worried that motion capturing and
keyframing the actors based on real
martial artists would actually make the
gameplay too different from your
standard Mortal Kombat game because
obviously a motion captured real-life
punch moves differently than a to frame
digitized animation of a punch so they
use the motion capture method and then
change the speed of these moves to make
them feel more like the 2d games so yes
it's a realistic motion of a punch but
it's sped up in the same amount of
frames as the digitized fighters the
result is just something looking
unrealistic but also not unrealistic
enough to be fun let's not also forget
to mention that these stages are very
plain-looking and really didn't need to
be in 3d since they look the same from
every direction this is the first of
quite a few MK games to use a 3d arena
so you have the revolutionary ability to
just sidestep attacks you and your
opponent can sidle around in the
backgrounds and find stuff to throw at
each other or well yeah that's about it
it kind of makes you wonder why they
even built the game like this was it
just because other games from around the
time we're doing it it was like a peer
pressure thing was it because they
started working in a 3d engine and
thought that had to be taken as
literally as possible and it wouldn't
count as 3d unless he could waddle into
the foreground and background it's just
kind of gimmicky and doesn't really add
anything which applies to a lot of
things in this game actually like the
weapons for the first time in an MK game
you can intentionally whip out a weapon
to stab poke your opponents with
although you'll be hard-pressed to get
lucky enough to use the thing because
you drop it if they hit you first then
they can pick it up and use it against
you which I guess was their attempt at
balance in the game but like it come on
wait hold on fire weapons even allowed
in mortal combat isn't there a rule
against that it's kind of unfair when a
guy can just pull out a gun and shoot
ever
one that's not a test of warrior skill
that's just cheating man what about the
guy that's like 9 feet tall and has a
giant Warhammer can we put in some kind
of weight class system to make it more
fair you know cuz like liu kang weighs
like 105 pounds it seems a little
unbalanced it is there is there a
handbook I can read on the rules this is
the first game in the series to use
alternate costumes and that's kind of
cool
some of them actually stuck and appear
in later games like Johnny suit
sub-zero's frozen limbs in this mix of
reptiles classic and scaly designs for
some reason in this game he's
considerably more reptilian probably
because they went overboard with the
ninjas in the last game I think this one
has by far the most annoying and hard to
pull off fatalities something about it
just doesn't seem to work I can't figure
out where to stand to do it right I'm
sure what do you MLG Bros will tell me
it's because I suck right yeah ok thanks
I know it's very important to be good at
Mortal Kombat 4 it's a cornerstone of
gaming culture after all anyway if you
do manage to do a fatality you'll find
the sound effects of blood of oka garden
hose splashing on concrete rather than
the sound of arterial spray
speaking of culture these cutscenes sure
are something to behold our story starts
with Raiden standing in the rain and
talking to no one I guess just kind of
going off he says that a few thousand
years ago one of the Elder Gods went
rogue and started committing God crimes
and trying to take over all the
different realms and after a few
genocides and retaliation Raiden helped
to banish him to the nether realm which
is where scorpion lives after Shao Kahn
is defeated in MK 3 she not get some
help from his buddy quan chi a sorcerer
who had seen the film powder of the
previous year and got way too into it
they escaped the hether realm and take
over katanas home dimension with the
power of this magic amulet MacGuffin
that we'll be fumbling around with for
the next six games plus a prequel so get
used to that the story this game is kind
of funny because there's not really like
a tournament anymore it ended when they
beat Shao Kahn it's it's gone this is
pretty much just people from Mortal
Kombat being drafted to fight a bad guy
that's taking over the multiverse
because Raiden needs P
we're good at fighting this will become
a big theme for the rest of the series
the n64 version the game had these
[Music]
wonderfully animated cutscenes using the
in-game models and environments due to
limitations in memory but the
PlayStation port really went all out and
took it a step further with these
gorgeous FMVs needless to say these
cutscenes aren't any better than CG
animation let's talk about a few of my
favorites shall we so I only played this
game twice a scorpion in sub-zero and I
got both their endings both endings are
basically the same scenario where they
fight and then discover that Quan Chi
just tricks scorpion into doing that
because he hated sub-zero's older
brothers so much due to prequel
shenanigans but only the scorpion one is
canon because he doesn't kill Quan Chi
in that one and also why did Quan Chi
want revenge on younger sub-zero for the
[ __ ] his brother did if he already knows
that scorpion revenged him for something
else some reason and scorpions endings
sub-zero toxin an Arnold Schwarzenegger
impression finish your quest for
vengeance is over scorpion but in his
own he doesn't your soul will never rest
scorpion
Queen may have been responsible for you
murder but your family's true killer
still remains free and in the n64
version of sub-zero's ending scorpion
says and sub-zero says I didn't I didn't
add that that's not a glitch because
they they even put a subtitle for that
what is that what is that in Sonja's
ending she tricks Jarek into falling off
a cliff in Jarek sending Sonya tricked
Jarek into falling off a cliff but then
he throws her off of the cliff and then
a Jax is ending Sonya tricked Jarek into
falling off of a cliff but then he
throws her off of the cliff then Jax
throws Jarek off the cliff again just to
make sure that it sticks
none of these are canon in reptiles
ending he asks for a favour and then
shinnok says No Reiko sits on a throne
and then puts on Shao Kahn's old helmet
a later game reveals the lore that this
is just the thing that he does and he
has an actually ruler of Outworld nor
does he secretly Shao Kahn he just he
just sneaks in there and plays pretend
that's it his n64 ending just has him
wordlessly walk into a portal probably
because they didn't want to make an
extra in-game asset for the chair of the
helmet what a banger of an ending 10 at
10 Johnny Cage is ending is the best in
the game because it appears to have
nothing to do with anything in a story
and it's just it's funny
Liu Kang gets a force ghost call from
katana asking him to come be the
permanent immortal ruler of the peaceful
realm called a denna
Adeiny ah God [ __ ] ah Liu Kang gets a
force ghost call from katana asking him
to come be the permanent immortal ruler
of a peaceful realm called a Denia as
her husband but then he's like nah I
cannot accept your offer
so bold strategy cotton let's see if it
pays off for bouquet is dead
so obviously the story for this game
lacks something to be desired but then
again that might be due to the problem
that would start plaguing the rest of
the Mortal Kombat series from this point
forward until like 19 years later this
series doesn't know how to make new
characters anymore well the first two
games seem to generate nothing but
memorable and interesting characters and
mk3 threw in a few duds but even they
had some charm mk4 is just sad about it
it's like they didn't even try look at
these guys they're just so boring to
even look at their names are boring
their moves are boring their faces are
boring while I respect the restraint
from just creating an infinite spectrum
of color-coded ninjas with thematically
corresponding superpowers the new ideas
just didn't seem to work no one
gravitates towards these guys no one
thinks they're interesting Kai is just
Liu Kang's friend that can also fight
that's it Reiko is a guy who doesn't
talk and has face paint like night wolf
I guess he was apparently supposed to be
noob saibot but fans complained about
too many ninja characters new being too
hard to see in some stages so they just
changed his outfit when hey look it's a
new guy which isn't a new thing but this
time it's not excusable because those
had unique personality and were
justifiable because they were the result
of technical limitations this was just a
lack of creativity Tania is there to
complete the female ninja set of colour
swaps and her personality is that she's
a traitor or something Jarek is exactly
identical to Kano in every way even in
terms of his place in the story he has
knose moves and even his fatalities and
he's from the same fictional gang as
Kano but they just took out his cyborg
parts because he was gay no and then at
the last minute they decided they wanted
to make a new character why does he have
a single laser eye then because Kano
taught him that trick it's just a thing
you can teach people
Kano runs an online course for it Fujin
all right so like you know how Raiden is
the god of thunder fusion is the god of
wind that's all you got no he's just his
elemental coworker with the exceptions
of Quan
she and shinnok who both have memorable
designs and character traits the new
rosters is full of bland new additions
it's just for normal looking dudes with
vaguely old European or vaguely old
Asian clothing what happened all the
creative and wacky ideas we get a cyborg
mercenary a Ghost Rider ninja a guy who
can kill people the magic hat and now we
have [ __ ] Kai these characters are so
forgettable that I actually got them
mixed up earlier and kept calling Jarek
Reiko and had to rewrite my script to
fix it maybe the series is lead
character designer John Tobias was
getting burnt out at this point didn't
bring his a-game because this was the
last main line entry in the series he
worked on but the thing that really
pushed him over the edge was awarding
the guys working on next is there an MK
5
m'kay bye
how about yourself down
we're also working on a game called
Mortal Kombat Special Forces which star
Sonya
[Music]
Wow let's not get ahead of ourselves
anyway it was a fun callback to reveal
Goro was still alive and just much of a
cheater as ever but the final boss was
laughably easy and didn't pose much of a
threat this is the only game in the
series to give you limited lives during
the challenge ladder I can only imagine
this as being implemented as a method of
keeping kids from hogging the machine at
the arcade I set those to the maximum
amount because goddamn it this is 2019
and the only reason to go to an arcade
is to make my 11 year old sister play
House of the Dead MK 4 is sort of a game
that we didn't need to exist it's full
of half-baked ideas that I'll just say
well I guess we should put this in now
between the new story new characters new
gameplay mechanics and new costumes they
all just kind of fall flat and I don't
think they knew how to pull it off or
had access to the technology at the time
to make it really work I think the
biggest misstep was the decision to stop
using digitized actors because look at
these same character designs in the
trailer for the game they had a budget
for costumes now they should have just
used these guys what a waste though
pretty much every game after MK 4 in the
series would use it as an influence and
thankfully incorporate its ideas in a
much better way it's what I consider a
real low point for Mortal Kombat so
let's make an extended edition on a
console no one wanted that stopped being
produced after three years
Mortal Kombat gold is just like Ultimate
Mortal Kombat 3 more characters added to
fill out a lackluster roster and that's
about it
thankfully they brought back plenty of
classics and there's some neat new lore
added in these extra endings like girl
becoming a good guy cyrix becoming a
human again and sektor hip thrusting
everyone to death because sonya left the
door to the lab open
dammit Sonya do you want wild cyber
ninjas just walking right in 3 out of 10
too much MSM I got the better
so shortly after that embarrassing train
wreck Midway decided they wanted to
branch out and start experimenting with
other types of games set in the Mortal
Kombat universe because that's just
ridiculous no one beats sub-zero one
thing led to another and we have a
spinoff prequel about big brother
sub-zero brings back digitized actors in
both gameplay and the cutscenes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I love it like this that was some
gangsta [ __ ] baby one she has once again
retained your services
yeah but you gonna have to pay me
smaller muscles too but let's just say
has great sentimental value it's an
action-adventure story about noob sub
bot who was hired by Quan Chi to steal
that magic medallion thing in the first
place along the way we get to see how
scorpion was killed
it's funny how this is such a massively
important moment in the series and it's
only ever visually represented in the
game through such a basic little
animation like 60% of the lore revolves
around this spine rib
anyway Quantico Chi wipes out scorpions
clan in exchange for Sub Zero going to
this big fortress full of elemental
warriors because of sub-zero's powers
he's apparently the only guy who can
fight said elemental warriors and also
Quan Chi just didn't want to go himself
his knees it was ironically I think
these cutscenes are the most charming
and interesting part of this game which
is a far cry from MK for the acting is
cheesy in the most lovable way and they
got back actors from the previous MK
games like the guy who played Kano
this is the same sub-zero from NK 3 plus
I just really liked the costumes
I used this sub-zero costume as a
reference when I made my own ninja
cosplay with the help of my mom and
grandma when I was about 12 it still
fits actually anywho this game has
plenty of characters to fight one of
which is the wind-god guy from MK 4 and
another is this Serena lady who shows up
in later games since you have the option
to spare her after her boss
so immortal has escaped from the
immortal yes immortal he is headed
towards the gates of immortality unload
the keepers and send the full garrison
sins herself make sure that he does not
cross the branch we have toyed with the
musician she'll even show up in the
final boss to help you kick Kwan and the
cheese sub-zero gets yelled at by
disappointed dad Raiden forgiving this
spooky looking drug dealer the MacGuffin
coin so he sends them to hell to get it
back
sub a Bubba stops more bad guys and then
even has another run-in with scorpions
you better lock me up still be alive
yeah it wasn't enough to kill
you had to destroy every last remnant of
my being including my wife and child
holding your hand fool get the army I'm
a [ __ ] maniac words will not save you
coupons get your face blank
full [ __ ] up by name unfortunately
sub-zero's new allies serena gets killed
by shinnok but in the MK getting killed
is just more of an inconvenience so
she'll be fine she knocks design in this
game is even less intimidating than the
last one but after you make him really
mad he turns into a giant super-powered
monster this is a thing he does
apparently I find myself really wanting
to like this game because the concept is
great just taking the stage borders off
the player and letting you continue
forward like a side scrollers really
neat and the story is interesting to me
well I think the graphics even look
pretty great but then there's a major
setback the gameplay I don't think I can
say much about it that other bigger
channels haven't covered but the
platforming in this game is a nightmare
train wreck that makes it almost
impossible to enjoy all this games
potential is killed by its brain-dead
decision to think deep at jumping could
work for this type of level design and
you have frosty ninja man trying to make
pinpoint-accurate jumps on TSP sized
platforms you know how you jump in
mortal combat to either get away from an
opponent or dive kick them in the face
it's not exactly a precision move it's
just about being offensive or defensive
you can't just apply that to a
side-scroller level and expect the game
to work exactly the same as Mario it's
not built for that so even though this
game has some really awesome boss
characters you'll never be able to find
them unless you use the level select
cheats or you're just crazy enough to
spend a few dozen hours trying to get
past these stupid wind temple sections I
wish someone could just make a mod for
this game to just take out the majority
of the platforming sections to make
matters worse your ice powers are
limited and can run out eventually which
makes everything even harder when earth
did we need some kind of inventory
system how about you just get more help
when you successfully kill an opponent
so if you combat ties every
enemy in the level before the boss
you'll be good and ready to take them on
instead of having to stock up on health
potions at the very least you can use
the switch directions button to make him
do a funny dance I can't fault Midway
for trying new things but they just
didn't go far enough out of their
comfort zone with this one but I still
find things about this game really cool
but just not having the patience to
really sit down and struggle through it
games are supposed to be fun not a chore
apparently people in the late 90s felt
pretty much the same about this game
that I did so a couple of planned
mythology's games about other characters
like Liu Kang or Baraka piraka Barack
Barack II broccoli your trash Brock
Spock the rock maracas Doc Ock Phil ARCA
and a parka were cancelled but Jack's
got one why does it smell like a Dan
Ford and catchphrase in here
[Music]
this is where the Mortal Kombat
franchise became irreparably damaged
when one of the biggest creative voices
behind it felt so stifled and beaten
down by developing this game that he
left the series behind forever and they
had to awkwardly cut around him in the
documentary footage her lair MK games
this game had a legendarily troubled
development over the course of three
years while one half of the duo behind
the series Ed Boon worked on Mortal
Kombat 4 and gold John Tobias was
saddled with this project over the
course of working on the game Tobias and
the team working under him found
themselves struggling to build a fully
3d experience because it was so far out
of their wheelhouse
it was a massive undertaking for them to
make this thing and as it took more and
more time
Tobias saw the end of the PlayStation 1
n64 and dreamcast coming over the
horizon as the new millennium approached
he found himself wanting to work on a
big-budget game for the new consoles
with a more capable team so four years
after mortal kombat 4 in 1999 left
Midway to start his own company which
was equally as unsuccessful as this game
this left the team for Special Forces
kind of discombobulated and unsure how
to even finish this beast of a project
so they scrapped most of their more
ambitious ideas and rushed out an
incredibly shallow basic and
underwhelming final product on the
PlayStation they didn't even bother
porting it to the other two systems like
they intended to originally they just
gave up but enough about the behind the
scenes mess you guys want to know about
the game itself and honestly it
disappointed me I feel like this one
kind of hit me at us for how bad it is
and I've heard people talk about it as
if though it's one of the worst games
ever made but it's not even that
noteworthy it's just kind of lame but
one this story is extremely absent Kano
breaks his clan of bad guys out of jail
including Jarek his biggest fan as we
know and a bunch of more generic bosses
and another ninja palette swap character
the last one we'll see in this series
actually because I guess Brown is the
only color they hadn't
yet so Jax decides to chase them down
from hideout to hideout and then
inevitably chases Kay no doubt world
discovering that he wanted to go there
to get this mystical gem of immense
power turns out that power is just to
teleport you back to earth an idiot this
is apparently the first story in the
entire Canon of the Mortal Kombat
universe despite the massive continuity
errors hanging from Jax's shoulder
stumps the gameplay is kind of slow and
clunky if you're using the d-pad to move
around you almost feel like you're
walking on a grid and the enemies stop
you dead in your tracks just by hitting
you but I found out if you turn on the
joystick control the game becomes
laughably easy because you can pretty
much just outmaneuver everyone and just
bash them in the head not to mention you
can find a silly amount of ammo lying
around to take everyone out at a
distance there's also a handful of
special moves that you can use to do a
lot of damage but who needs that when
you have a machine gun that never needs
reloading you can zoom in and shoot from
a first-person con angle but it's only
really ever useful in one part of the
game and the auto aim tracks so well on
the third-person that you'd never really
need it levels range from relatively
simple linear jeonse to maze like
labyrinths of low poly walls that all
look the same every level seems to
introduce a new mechanic and then forget
it exists when the next level rolls
around then maybe it'll come back like
two or three levels later like using
these detonators to blow up walls and
reveal secret passages that just stops
being a thing after a while or this
mechanic for pushing boxes you only use
that once you only need to climb up on
top of something twice in the whole game
you'll have an inventory menu for some
reason despite only getting like two key
items at most in a single time so all it
does is give you a brief respite from
the bosses hitting you to heal up before
getting back to the combat with a K it's
easy to get lost in these levels if you
have a bad sense of spatial awareness
and a map would have been really helpful
at times but I still majid my way
through these dark and drab areas with
ease during a special noise chat session
with my patrons I'm gonna start doing
those every two weeks now so if you want
a chance to talk with me while I play
crappy games like this one it's only
dollar away speaking of selling out this
game the bosses are all relatively easy
they use some kind of special attack
that hurts at a distance but as soon as
you get in close they can't really do
anything to stop you if you have the
ammo to spare you can just post up in
the corner and unload on them from a
distance the machine gun stuns them so
hard they get locked in place and can't
do anything until you're done firing my
favorites in the game are Jarek because
he's just so sad it's funny and tremor
because he's the only one that's kind of
cool but ain't broke don't fix it color
swap ninjas are cool man I can't help
but notice this is the first time we see
Kano post Mortal Kombat movie and his
design and voice are trying to match his
film actor so what happens when a
low-budget cheesy overacted 90's movie
character is translated into a cheesy
low-budget 90s ps1 game character bad
things it's a shame that he was a victim
of the silent killer that is male
pattern baldness before the first game
story
this boss fight is sad guess that counts
as a fatality since he exploded I found
a video online where someone posted rare
footage from my much earlier build of
the game remember they said Sonya was
gonna be in it well Sonya was gonna be
in it she was fully playable in her own
concurrent level separate from the ones
with Jax and then for some reason she
was totally removed later in development
it's kind of weird though because Jax
talks to some lady named gem and I on
the radio between missions and it would
have been really easy to just change her
name to Sonya so we at least know she
exists instead of just not mentioning
her at all the older version has all
in-game cutscenes and if you can look
past the hideous texture clipping ps1
style character models either kind of
impressive from a technical standpoint
just because of how complex they are
there's also a lot of voice acting these
guys chased us around the world they
want their nuke back I say we give it a
woman get him off our tails you're going
soft on us cabal huh we just Massacre
the hosts quanta Special Forces goods
and you want to just give up and give
him back that toy you know what that
gadgets worth 500 600 million apparently
even more characters were planned to be
included like cabal prior to getting his
homeless Darth Vader makeover
the writing is what do you want now I
have to use the toilet so use the toilet
there's one in your cell but I can't my
hands are cuffed I ain't taking off your
cups well then can you at least come in
and pull my pants down for me Oh need
some work if we take a look at the
gameplay they had originally it's almost
completely different this had a more
dynamic camera that followed along
behind the player bigger and more
complicated levels a jumping and
climbing mechanic and just
better-looking animations color me
impressed I know this is unfinished but
it still looks League
better than what we got I think this
would have pushed the playstation do
with technical limits just a run it's a
shame we never got this game considering
how different the released product is
from the demo you have to wonder just
what the hell happened behind the scenes
that led to such a drastic change some
people theorize that the team behind the
game trashed all of this save for the
character models and just started over
from scratch after tobias left in 1999
which means the 2000 release game would
have been made in less than a year just
to finally have it be done with thus
ends what I have affectionately titled
in my project files as Mortal Kombat's
that Mortal Kombat went from owning the
gaming world to being the reason the
gaming world was so controversial for a
time to just being another franchise
with no clear direction and too much
demand for sequels there's a very ugly
period of history in the late 90s and
early 2000s where this series struggled
to evolve alongside the technology of
its time Midway tried all kinds of
ambitious new ideas in three different
ways they just fell flat because they
either didn't know how to use the gaming
techniques of their time didn't know how
to build upon what they had already
established as functional or just didn't
know how to reinvent their series in a
satisfying way and we're pushing around
so many polygons and the details so
incredible and really was so incredible
but that still wasn't enough before we
talk about the new era of MK s game
installments I think it's important to
focus on that word franchise because
this became so much more than just a few
games this was a pop cultural phenomenon
that blew up in a wave of different
products adaptations and merchandising
next time I think it could be fun to
sidetrack for a while and talk about
every other Mortal Kombat thing from the
90s so real quick who's your favorite
character out of all
scorpion absolutely scorpion visually I
said Goro
well I got to tell you guys this is my
favorite right
sorry
[Music]
[Music]